oui je tourne s'excuser autres
aujourd'hui sur la deuxième partie de
dsk new way temps la map qu'on avait
commencé la dernière fois alors c'est
parti on se met direct dans l'ambiance
bim
on en était arrivé là on venait de là
bas on arrivait dans le laboratoire et
j'ai trouvé le put de cette puce thomas
pour doit trouver une potion avec qui
nous sortira des mauvais esprits un truc
comme ça bon en fait on réagit mal
compris ça va plus vite
alors est ce que j'aurai pas des choses
cachées dans cet endroit sinistre sous
l'escalier la des tiroirs il ya pas de
la mode ou non ya pas d'émeutes ou alors
est ce qu'on peut j'écris avait un mec
là où j'étais en train de me pose dessus
comme toujours
alors on reste porte coucou un homme nu
tu lui est il arrivé
quand est il arrivé bordel ils sont
toujours là ils sont toujours présents
ils sont avait au menu
alors on a un livre bat logiquement se
trompe on est peut-être à la fin du jeu
une clé
au shit non non non tu ne peux pas
rentrer je mettais trop de vent vite
vite les tonneaux vie tu ne peux pas
rentrer s'est occupé s'est occupé s'est
occupée des gages crois toi ça boit ça
marche
c'est passé pas pour tous mpt 28 mois
avec nos petits rôles ou ses terres
c'était un cul de combien ok allez on
continue à peaches bordel de verdi
losail nous avons une chaude one shot
alors est-ce qu'on peut annoncer sérieux
là mais c'est qu'elle porte en fait que
ça nous permet d'ouvrir je comprends pas
trop où on va devoir revenir en arrière
non il ya forcément un petit truc caché
vers ici est ce qu'on a au moins garder
la clé oui on a alors dit à the beat of
trust i need d'accord alors doit
peut-être avoir un endroit caché e o
et alors est ce qu'on peut pas tirer
trop lourd [ __ ] je pensais pas qu'il
pouvait ne pas retirer des objets bon
alors est-ce qu'il ya pas un truc à
aller voir là où une trappe secrète vers
le haut un truc non alors le seul moyen
c'est peut-être de revenir en arrière
ma foi et trouver une autre porte [ __ ]
qu'est ce que c'est que le bordel de
merde j'en ai marre des jeux bloc je
transpire inquiet je transpire un coût
non mais c'est toi tu bloques là bas
[ __ ] j'ai cru qu'ils étaient vivants
j'ai cru qu'il avait pris vie le [ __ ]
est-ce qu'il ya pas une porte ici non
des tiroirs non nadjaf et où il n'avait
pas l'air d'avoir une grande porte
on n'a presque plus d'huile on va vite
remonter la semaine porte yes yes j'ai
bien fait ok c'est bon on a trouvé la
boîte info qu il n ya qu il a fait un
caméo
il a fait un kamehameha dans la formule
quoi the way it is now let this madness
ok donc voilà je viens will never be
free donc en fait on a fait toute
l'histoire dans la première partie
bon je pense qu'on marche et les amplis
c'est un homme nul qui nous dit que
c'est fini bonbons pour montrer le
niveau de cette piste homme serait bon
je pense qu'on va finir
on va faire notre culture tout rien
parce que là c'était pas assez alors on
en fait une autre de suite on enchaîne
alors nouvelle a donc sur une autre
custom tories là ça s'appelle troll
story je comprends absolument pas
pourquoi j'ai apparu je me suis déjà
fait taper eux c'est une puce comme
souris qui datent pas mal bon comme son
nom ces trolls story revoilà avons par
exemple on a une clé qui fait 4 mètres
de long
ok je sens la halle avec story vraiment
juste ignoble
bon c'est pas grave bon on commençait
une clé gérante trouvait hier en cage
est un homme nu qui apparaît devant nous
tout va bien what
les gens nous sommes à mal tous
millionnaires
on va juste prendre de lui l'un l'aurait
je pense qu'on s'en fout un peu mon avis
ça sert à rien c'est juste un gros troll
genre de l'est voici les potions et
plein de trucs en masse ok parfait
d'accord on continue salut [ __ ] mais
ils vont nous suivent sur combien de
custom story c'est foutu sommes nulles
ah mais c'est pas possible une porte une
porte de 4 mètres de large
bah moi c'est pas moi c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi laissez moi c'est moi j'ai
un homme le team protège
j'ai un homme de paix un homme nu qui
protège fait gaffe à toi
non non non non non non il y en eut
contenu est roi
qu'est ce qu'on boit pas si tu le
où vas tu te connais sous-estiment
jamais pouvoir de l'homme nu par
d'autres choses et ce thème jamais de
petit quand je te regarde dans les yeux
vient de battre c'est énorme
voilà c'est bien donc il y en a des
cauchemars pour des cochons parce que là
nos potes il est également en train de
mourir le pôle position de raison et la
passion de vue pour la lanterne est ok
c'est merveilleux alors est ce qu'on
peut
je suppose c'est encore un voile à ok
très bien est ce que on peut arrêter les
blagues nulles bordel ça fait chier à la
fin alors ici avait un barbecue avec des
fans bleus a pas demandé des flammes
bleues apparemment pardon excusez moi je
suis encore dans le délire de bikini
baid à laquelle jeu incroyable on peut
sortir quoi là mais que gatti de l'autre
côté de cette fameuse salle je me le
demande
vous vous demandez aussi eh ben il n'ya
peut-être horaire il ya peut-être des
hommes new géant tata incroyable talent
le mec qu'a fait cet historique c'est un
souci quoi alors on va mettre des sommes
jugées injustes la brave est une clé
géant club parce que j'adore tous kg 1
on va mettre une tête de mort dans ce
recueil j'ai ramassé la tête d'agrippa
alors à quoi elle donc c'est lui agrippe
ah ok arrive à paris john tu veux ta
tête tu en voilà tagro est ce qu'on veut
pas lui mettre alors dommage ça aurait
été pas mal qu'on puisse le mettre sa
tête bon malheureusement peut pas lui
rendre c'est dommage on est un peu des
rames
alors en quoi alors cet homme bague
légèrement c'est un salut ça va tu sais
le retour du bras de la dernière fois
souvenez-vous peau est de retour il est
9 août où il est là il
il a drôlement grandi depuis notre
dernière rencontre on est peut-être
quelque chose là dedans on n'a
absolument rien bon alors peut-être dans
celle ci une clé
bâtard non non non non c'est bon sens au
sein regarder on s'en sort c'est
avrillas les amis de droite jacques sans
abri un patin vous devez continuer un
petit peu tu es toujours etc noté sur un
désert n'oubliez pas il évite skinner un
fake bref un fait très amusant ainsi
soit il bon du coup on doit se retaper à
l homme nu et a pas bougé tchèque j'ai
commencé mon pote allons continuer ce
qu'il y aurait pas autre chose à faire
ici j'aime bien cette map elle est
marrante alors [ __ ] mais ces hommes
géants font quand même à bas voilà une
arme un poignard au c'est pour la piñata
ont fait une pile à temps boyard ok bon
ainsi soit il alors c'est quand même la
map la plus la plus grotesque de tous
les temps un troll story c'est du troll
à l'état pur des choses plutôt pas drôle
mais bon au final on en rigole on va
vers où
d'accord il n'y avait pas d'indication
vous allez à travers une porte tout va
bien alors excuse
sérieux ça
what the fuck
bordel de merde on se casse le singe
invisible tu arrêtes y en a marre hop on
attache ça moi je m'attarde pas trop ici
je vous préviens avance après après les
shows géantes et les choses minuscules à
à l'hôpital de troll la porte la plus
petite du monde
c'est juste pour passer batta tasse de
thé en fait c'est juste pour donner à
manger à l'escalier bon allez on
continue
allez on y va salut bonjour qu'est ce tu
fais là bon en fait on va engager pour
contrôler tout est ok sortez moi de
cette christophe ettori de merde et les
pitié de moi
sérieux comme [ __ ] mais c'est quoi ce
bordel
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya là dedans un
canapé mais tout va bien canapé ya quoi
peut-être sur lie encore un truc
absolument pas des gages qu'est ce qu'un
pied de biche salut tuer l'âme au pied
de biche houle comme en volume + bus je
m'en bats les couilles à la jeu mais les
opus est bâtard alors est ce que j'aurai
pas dans ses tiroirs des choses
intéressantes non plus dans ce truc non
plus fort et et dire non plus de parler
vite non plus d'accord bah je crois
qu'on peut se passer par la porte en
fait finalement alors ça c'était sur la
porte bloquée fallait s'y attendre
mandat fc peut-être le tapis non il est
peut-être un peu trop grand pour le
bouger celui ci finalement la statue
peut-être que la mythique paris sinon je
ne sais pas [ __ ] mais je suis sûr qu'à
une clé ici bordel c'est pas possible
mais où elle et ça je ne sais pas c'est
pas là en tout cas pas dans ce tiroir
montrions celui ci notre client celui-ci
bordel sont ils des formes open planquer
des aaa un levier et ça fait quoi
absolument rien peut-être s'est ouvert
la porte vous pensez y est encore des
singes invisible qui joue avec les
lustres
mais ça ne va pas du tout alors droite
ou gauche
quand vous le sentez droite c'est une
porte gauche et où on va on va tenter
d'aller à gauche
faire le tour de la mince affaire mais
celle ci est celle ci yes
ouais
dabbashi je me couche est devenu papa
peta dans un mur soit jours du père
texte intimider avec la tête de grille
pain j'ai la tête de louis paul si tu
m'attaques je vais bonal 0 c'est ok je
propose qu'on fasse un rouge à droite
3 2 1 il y avait une porte l'âge où elle
danse est forte
non on doit un prix
ouais non
non non non c'est bon port par terme ces
passeports dont dispose de maputo bordel
de merde qui a créé cette map ridicule
oh non mais stop le bruit la saison là
haut
ce qui est bien le fils du monde mais
j'ai mal au dos voilà la cause de vos
conneries
qu'est-ce qu'on tente
je pense que ça au vert la porte qui est
là bas à gauche on va dans l'apport
qu'il avait à gauche on y va j'aimerais
bien qu'ils me tuent parce que là la
musique c'est simplement insupportable
allez viens de bhatti était un homme
vierge et un poignard
aux castels j'en ai marre jaune ma
claque
15 d'ici
ah c'est celui là
ça fait tellement du bien
ce casque allez voici dans un pays on
est dehors oui au super
mais voire athées de mettre des mots
spartoo ago tu te fais une pause et que
tu te relâches sur les braises chacun
son truc
alors est-ce que ça va voilà voilà où
tout va bien c'est la même plate plus
what the fuck de tous les temps tout va
bien
salut mais attend et ça fait un peu
salines team sebah
on court vite oh [ __ ] non c'est
ingérable champlain boys champions
[ __ ] pourquoi ça fait ça pourquoi ça a
fait ça je ne comprends pas adieu balma
bon on va dire que c'est fait exprès
comme ça on est tombé dans l'éternité
alors voilà heureusement qu'on est mort
tu as le bug dont ils nous ont emmenés
dans les abysses quoi je mets tout va
bien tous ces genres dégage
allez on y retourne à du coup je cours
vite de base
[ __ ] de bordel de merde ça sent ça
sent pas bon j'ai pas terrain de foirer
faut bien viser les marches qui sont là
ok parfait
allez allez allez monter mon propre
compte voilà un cabanon qui amasse
annick et où le script du coup et on
tombe là dedans et c'est la fin tout va
bien j'espère que ça vous aura plu en
tout cas moi ça ne m'a pas plus que ça
se retrouve bientôt une nouvelle vidéo
avec des joies de presse notamment de la
pêche courant des buttes chaumont et
crise et à bientôt